Karaman Maras in der Nähe des
Epizentrums in den Trümmern liegen immer
noch Körper von Verstorbenen
deutsche Bestatter sind vor Ort es ist
eine Arbeit unter extremen Bedingungen
hier auf dem Trümmerfeld hinter uns
haben wir versucht den noch mindestens
drei Kinder rauszuholen und hier sollten
aber auch noch drei Erwachsene liegen
das ganze Existenzen ausgelöscht worden
sind das ist schon sehr tragisch
das berührt einen schon wenn man hier
Bilder sieht die herumliegen Fotoalben
Kuscheltiere
ein paar Tage vorher Flughafen Frankfurt
die zehn Männer kurz vor dem Abflug ins
Katastrophengebiet
was in der Türkei auf sie zukommt das
können sie zu dem Zeitpunkt nur erahnen
auf das was uns jetzt de facto erwartet
kann man sich wahrscheinlich nicht
vorbereiten was wir natürlich
vorbereiten sind Abläufe und solche
Dinge in Rahmen von Übungen die
Situation ist ja so dass der Zeitraum
jetzt schon etwas fortgeschritten ist
und die Verstorbenen Körper halt auch
nicht mehr so schön sind und das ist
seit einem nicht so toller Anblick den
man dann teilweise auch hat und wir
reden natürlich auch über Kinder und das
ist eine Sache die ja keiner mag aber
wir sind halt dafür da
im Ball man nennen sie sich
Einbalsamierer sie haben alle einen
Zusatzausbildung um Körper von
Verstorbenen so zu behandeln dass eine
würdevolle Beisetzung möglich ist der
heißt der Verein es sind lauter
freiwillige zu Hause haben die meisten
eigene Bestattungsunternehmen
[Musik]
wir arbeiten jeden Tag mit Verstorbenen
und demzufolge ist für uns leichter
damit umzugehen wenn irgendwie Respekt
vor Angst vor oder mit beide geht man
runter mit einem großen Teil Respekt und
Angst ist ja es fällt immer dabei falls
was passieren könnte natürlich ob einem
selber oder aus der Gruppe
dann geht es los ins Erdbebengebiet in
die Türkei
Karaman Maras eine Stadt im Süden
Anatoliens mit fast 700.000 Einwohnern
etwas so groß wie Frankfurt
im Zentrum der Stadt sind ganze
Straßenzüge durch das Beben zerstört
worden
alleine in Kahraman Maras soll noch
hunderte Menschen in den Trümmern liegen
Bagger tragen den Schutt ab vorsichtig
um die Körper von Verstorbenen nicht zu
beschädigen
Einsatzort für den deutschen Bestatter
Benjamin Rosenthal er soll Ausschau
halten nach den Verstorbenen um sie
möglichst unbeschadet zu werden
auf diesem Grundstück werden noch sieben
Menschen vermisst
darunter sind auch drei Kinder
wir begleiten die Baggerfahrer wir
beobachten mit wenn wir irgendwo
verstanden Teile finden und sobald
irgendjemand was findet rufen die uns
und wir versuchen dann den Körper
Freien und das machen wir in hier
tagsüber mit dem Teams die du überall
unterwegs sind
[Musik]
es ist einfach für die deutschen
Bestatter die Grundstücke zu finden wo
sie suchen müssen nämlich dort wo
Angehörige Tag und Nacht ausharren weil
sie Gewissheit haben wollen dass ihre
Toten auch wirklich geborgen werden
da ist natürlich mit den Bildern aus dem
Medien hergereist und ja das wenn man
das live sieht übertrifft anders
natürlich vollkommen überliegen
persönliche Sachen rum überall liegen
Bilder rumliegen Fotoalben rum viele
Hinterbliebene wenn die Sachen aus den
Trümmern finden legen die die vor die
Trümmer Stelle oder hängen die an die
Bäume an und so das ist dann schon wenn
man guckt sich das an aber man denkt
nicht weiter darüber nach weil sonst
könnten wir das hier so nicht machen
die psychische Belastung für die
deutschen Bestatter ist immens auch wenn
sie in ihrer Arbeit ständig mit dem Tod
konfrontiert sind das Ausmaß dieser
Katastrophe eine der schlimmsten der
letzten Jahrzehnte übersteigt alles was
Sie bislang gesehen haben
hinzu kommt die physische Anstrengung
mehr als drei vier Stunden Schlaf sind
selten drin
wir fangen meistens so gegen acht an und
gehen treffen uns dann hier auf die
einzelnen Baustellen suchen Kontakt zu
welchen wo wir wissen da sind werden
noch für Leute vermutet dann gehen wir
mal uns in unsere Basis zurück essen was
und dann geht es aber nachts weiter weil
nachts arbeiten meistens nur die
Baggerfahrer und die Hüft ob Sie von
hier sehr ruhig aus und dann übernehmen
wir dann und manchmal ging es auch schon
bis
auch die Gefahr ist ein ständiger
Begleiter der Bestatter
bei Nachbeben stürzen immer wieder
beschädigte Gebäude ein
dabei sterben auch Menschen die in ihre
Wohnung gehen um ihr habt und gut zu
retten
wir dürfen mit den Hinterbliebenen nicht
reden sie sollen vor den Medien
geschützt werden auch wenn wir den
Eindruck haben dass manche sich sogar
gerne mitteilen würden
auch die deutschen Bestatter erleben das
immer wieder
es ist halt schon noch zu spüren dass
alle Menschen sehr betroffen sind die
haben also sehr viel Menschen hier
verloren die genaue Zahl ist gar nicht
bekannt und da ist es schon so dass man
hier viel Emotionen auf dem Straßen
erlebt die Menschen kommen zu einem
bedanken sich dass wir da sind und
unsere Arbeit hier durchführen und da
ist es schon so dass man da emotional
schon manchmal sehr angespannt ist
die deutschen arbeiten mit den
türkischen Rettungskräften eng zusammen
vor allem mit der Feuerwehr
der gemeinsam erlebte Kampf gegen die
Tragödie schweißt zusammen in wenigen
Tagen sind in den Ruinen von Karaman
Maras deutsch-türkische Freundschaften
entstanden
das berühmte war schon dass wir auch
einen trauerfeld wo ähm der Hund immer
angeschlagen hatte es war nicht sicher
ob das ein ein Hund war auf lebende oder
verstorbene und dann wurde noch eine
Wärmebildkamera eine Spezialisten
zugezogen und dann waren auch noch wer
will Signaturen zu sehen und dann wurde
die Nacht natürlich sehr lang weil man
die Hoffnung hatte dass wir dann wurden
auch Hohlräume gefunden dass wir
natürlich noch mal Überlebenden finden
können und was nicht unwahrscheinlich
war aber ein Tag vorher haben wir noch
hier in dem in der Stadt zwei haben
gefunden aber es war nicht so wir haben
leider irgendwann abbrechen müssen weil
es dann einfach zu lang war
[Musik]
die Toten werden schließlich in dieses
Gebäude gebracht eine Sporthalle hier
arbeiten die Deutschen bestatterhand in
Hand mit den türkischen Staatsanwälten
wir nehmen die Verstorbene entgegen wir
bereiten quasi die Entnahmen vor wir
reinigen die Finger so dass die Abdrücke
genommen werden können wir helfen bei
der Entnahme der DNA Proben und im
Anschluss wird der Verstorbene von uns
so fachmännisch desinfiziert dass keine
Krankheiten oder solchen auftreten
können das ist halt eine Situation immer
dann schwierig wenn er natürlich Kinder
dabei sind wenn die Mütter herkommen
dann ist das schon schwierig
in den ersten Tagen lag die Halle noch
voller toter Körper die deutschen
Bestatter arbeiteten Tag und Nacht damit
die Hinterbliebenen in würdevollerweise
Abschied nehmen kann
wie verarbeiten die Freiwilligen aus
Deutschland diese massive nicht enden
wollende Konfrontation mit dem Leid der
Trauer und dem Tod
noch ist es so dass das Gefühl
eigentlich so ist dass sie einen ganzen
Eindrücke erschlagen und man nicht
wirklich darüber nachdenkt weil man
einfach ganz viel am Arbeiten ist und
dann machen ist und durch die ganze
Herzlichkeit und Dankbarkeit der Leute
die wir ja fahren fängt dann das sehr
gut auf und unsere Gruppe ist auch so
dass wir ein sehr gutes Team sind ja wir
haben schon viel Gesprächsthemen dann
abends wenn wir jetzt beim Sitzen oder
man nimmt sich mal einen Arm und jeder
kann so ein bisschen auch das erzählen
was er so erlebt hat und das ist auch
ganz wichtig damit also diese Sachen
auch ausgesprochen werden
nach 7 Tagen ist der Einsatz für die
deutschen Bestatter vorbei
insgesamt etwa 1000 Tote haben sie in
dieser Zeit geborgen und ihren
Angehörigen übergeben
die Eindrücke aus Karaman Maras im
Zentrum des Bebens werden sie für immer
in sich tragen